You're listening to one of the scheme of
Russell brand,
Mike Esterday,
Scott Hindi.
Andrew's an offer,
an associate professor in sociology and
he's also doing the first black studies
degree anywhere in Europe at Birmingham
City University.
His research specialism is race and
racism is director of the Center for
critical social research,
founder of the Organization of black
unity and coach out of the black studies
association is contributed features to
the Guardian and his new book,
black radicalism is out next year.
Welcome Chi.
Hello.
Thanks for having me on.
Really greatly to come on as you know,
like that my motivation for doing these
podcasts because I'm at.
So as university you've been doing it
degree religion in global politics and
what I felt like the sort of a
dilettante's glee at new information.
And then like when I was sort of getting
given essays and stuff,
I think,
you know,
the minute I could meet these people,
I've been on the tele.
So this is part of that is in a way it's
like make a wish foundation just for
one,
making one person's wishes come true.
Um,
so we wanted to start around the area of
empire because a sort of national
identity,
a ethnocentric national identity in
particular becoming very prevalent both
in our country and America.
Wanted to talk to you about colonial
nostalgia and would you explain what
that term means and what this particular
moment around brexit and trump,
if you've got any analysis on them,
like to kick us off with?
Yeah,
so I mean the term colonial nostalgia,
it kind of refers to if you look at the
public discourse,
particularly around brexit and the vote
leave campaign and the idea that Britain
is great and Britain can go back to the
time it was great.
Well the time that Britain was great was
when it was an empire when it rolled
over 25 percent of the world when the
colonies stretched out to the empire.
The Sun never sets.
And that is the basis of,
of Britain's wealth today.
And that is kind of what people are
looking back at.
How do we go back to that colonial
prestige of Britain Nebula?
So when we say greatness mean tyranny
and oppression effectively.
Yeah.
With this,
this is what we're celebrating and
because we teach empire so badly,
we don't really understand the horror.
I mean,
the British empire was killed more
people than the Nazis.
Uh,
it was literally a form of fascism that
laid waste to whole whole areas of the
world and hope peoples of the world
quiet if like an institution or nation
killed more people than the Nazis.
And the main reason we think the Nazis
are bad is because they killed so many
people.
Does that mean the British empire was
worse than the Nazis?
Yeah,
I mean,
in some ways actually the British empire
and the Nazi's aren't separate in any
way,
shape or form.
There's a book that I'm Bauman
sociologist called and road where he's
called Holocaust and identity,
and actually argues that how we think
about the Holocaust.
These though somehow alien,
it's so outside.
It was so horrible.
It could never possibly fit within our
wonderful enlightened society.
But actually in the book he makes the
argument that the west modality
capitalism is the only society that
could have produced the Holocaust.
And the reason for that is racial
science.
When you think about the idea that Jews
aren't really people and we can prove
they're not people from measuring in
food science,
what end,
that's race,
that's the same racism which produced
slavery.
It says that I'm not fully a person and
you can treat me like cattle.
That's the same,
same racism,
the same science that proved that Jews
were in human.
And also if you think about the,
the amount of death,
that scientific process of death,
there's nothing new about that for the
Holocaust.
I mean Belgium,
uh,
the killed about 10 million people in
the Congo slavery wasted.
It was millions and millions of people.
So in a sense the holocaust is like the
logic of capitalism just don't tell
people we consider white and so it
becomes law.
He's horrible.
Right?
Right.
As far as two things,
yes,
of course it was people that were white.
And also I suppose in terms of their
trajectory,
it was a innovative commerce,
civilized country where people live in
civilized lives and the victims were
civilized.
So in a way,
I suppose it reveals a lot about our
presumptions around race,
if you wouldn't even in a modern
context,
I mean contemporary context.
Consider that was the same.
Yeah,
but hold on a minute that it was all
living in Africa and that it's not as
bad because I didn't have net cut and.
No,
and that's the problem,
right?
So big you see the logic of the western
imperialism in Europe for white people
and then you see it,
this is terrible.
But actually if you look the Holocaust
is,
if you think of the Holocaust is being
one of many imperial terrible things
that happened.
It's really not even in the top 10,
right?
Right.
Because it is the way that we categorize
this information of like,
you know,
like,
like as if there's a like a handicap
system,
apply it.
He's was white people.
So that's the worst.
Then down at like that.
So,
uh,
your obviously right,
thanks for illuminating me on that.
Now,
um,
how is that idea progressing and how is
that perpetuate in the idea of racial
science and that term?
I know from school net crow politics,
how does that,
how is that continuing now?
Where is the,
what's the front line of these arguments
that are at their most evident in the
most evident form of slavery and
Holocaust?
What's the version of that we're living
with now?
Yeah.
So after the Holocaust and then people
see like racial science is,
is terrible,
and actually maybe we should move away
from racial science.
And before the Holocaust he was just
science.
It wasn't racial science and it wasn't
controversial.
Correct.
That was just what we all kind of
agreed.
But when you see that happen,
uh,
to the Jews,
I see that the terror of it in Europe,
we've kind of abandoned race.
So will hear people will say race
doesn't exist.
Racist,
problematic.
We should move away from the idea of
race,
uh,
moved to ethnicity.
The problem is the way that we think
about ethnicity is basically exactly the
same way.
We thought about rates.
So there's different ethnic groups,
but their racialized.
So I'm Caribbean,
but then you lumping Caribbean with
African on the black,
then you have Asian,
which is India and Pakistan,
et Cetera.
Then you have mixed and even if you look
at the sensors,
the hierarchy of white to black is
actually visually represented,
right?
It's white,
Irish and then he's Asian.
Then it's mixed.
He's black and you see they actually,
the way we talk about ethnicity,
he still says that black people may not
be inferior because of biology anymore
were inferior because of our culture,
because of language,
because of our traditions,
because we haven't got any history.
So it's just a,
it's just a different version of the
same thing I thought was interesting.
So power you say mew tights but doesn't
often accede in.
I like,
it's like,
oh,
we can't do it in that way anymore,
but it is a new way.
Yeah,
exactly.
I think about,
if you think about what's,
what's,
uh,
racism really fundamentally about,
it's about creating a system that says
you have Europe,
what are the top,
you have Africa black the button and
there's various gradations in between.
And that is actually what global
politics look like today.
It's not a coincidence that the poorest
countries in the world are in Africa and
the richest countries in the world,
the European West white countries.
That's.
That's how it was designed for 500 years
ago.
And that is exactly how it is today.
What possible.
Other argument could there be other than
previous colonial exploitation,
some actual meritocracy?
Is that the actual argument?
The flat white European,
small advanced.
It's different and Africa,
it's primitive.
Terror is maintained.
If you think about are you doing a
degree in international relations and
international development?
I've been going around to a lot of
places recently saying,
well actually what do they teach?
And even international development,
they're teaching you how to
underdeveloped parts of the world.
I mean there's a whole.
A whole colonial education system isn't
just about Britain.
It's about the elite from Africa,
Caribbean and Asia coming into Europe
and learning about economic policies and
political ideas which are actually there
in place to continue the oppression of
the of the country.
So you have this idea that you can
develop the global south through aid and
through technology and through et
Cetera,
et cetera.
We've missed the point and it actually
these places of the world of poor
because the West is rich.
That was the same then as it is today.
That hasn't changed in any way,
shape or form.
It's integral,
I suppose,
isn't it,
that that story is concealed because it
is at odds with the assumption of
Justice and Mary that is required to
maintain a power balance.
Yeah,
exactly.
I actually talk about whiteness as being
more like a psychosis than like anything
else,
right?
The idea of whiteness and progress and
civilization,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
The ideas in the enlightenment that
Europe is kind of the civilizing mission
that spreads that truth to the world.
That's not rational.
I mean there's no rational basis did it,
right?
Because there's a lot of.
I don't know if you've read any critical
whiteness studies,
people like David Rottiger and I'm
knolling native who talk about the idea
that you can kind of teach at whiteness.
If only white people would understand
the problem historically,
then they'd change and become allies and
we'd all be happy.
Families actually I argue,
is much,
much,
much more serious than that.
The reason you have this myth of
progress,
etc.
Is because that within the political
economy,
the west needs to exploit the wrist and
so what we do is we have this psychosis
which says,
actually no.
NIce,
all right,
it's fine.
We're doing a good job,
etc.
Etc.
and that's to hide the fact that
actually the we're really living on the
back of children dying.
I mean that's what we're doing,
right?
Children die because of the system which
gives us money and so because we can't
deal with it mentally,
emotionally,
we create these myths about how
wonderful the world is,
right?
So it's like I say,
psychosis that has to conceal its
essence in order to perpetuate.
And even as sort of a little while ago
and that t via online news blog either.
We did an episode on like literal kids
mining for some resource for your mobile
phone.
So it made a very clear connection
between,
here we are in the weft,
ordinary people that don't feel like
we've got blood on our hands,
but in our handheld device is like,
here he is,
he's seven years old.
He's got to go down.
Oh no,
it's like a ballroom.
And you feel like it doesn't belong in
your understanding of the contemporary
world.
Now one of these things about whiteness
as power.
Obviously I as a white person that feel
I like,
I have certain attitudes towards the
state and my sense of alliance and
allegiance Would be countercultural.
How am I categorized by a,
like in the terms of this new emergent
narrative around power and oppression?
Uh,
it's interesting because this whole
discussion about like white allies and
it had this,
had this,
it was oxford yesterday talking about
this and sometimes I feel a bit like a
standup comedian when you kind of go
around and he played the little display,
the audiences and you get different
reactions and you tested your material.
It's good because I feel like an
academic.
Because when you said I've done this at
oxford is good already.
At the same level as oxford university
with my questions,
but it was good because they actually is
a question of whiteness came up,
you know,
what can white people do where the white
people,
what can we do to solve the problem,
the federal,
and it's.
It's a tricky question because if you
take my idea,
if you take what I'm arguing here that
whiteness is a psychosis and psychosis
are irrational,
so and actually in the left you can see
this as much as you can see on the
right,
so you have left wing people,
swp marxist who will make these global
arguments about x,
y,
zed who will say they were on the side
of the oppressed,
but actually when you look at what
they're saying that they,
they just as deluded as the right wing
fascist because whiteness as a concept
is so important.
And I'll give you an example I'm at,
so anybody anybody's black and knows and
goes to black events and african
caribbean community,
the swp,
a socialist workers party,
they're more prevalent than the police.
I mean they every day they're always
there.
They're always there peddling marxism,
marxism,
and I quite like mugs and by the way,
but one of these events,
there was a,
it was a few years ago,
there was a strike of set african farm
workers and teachers were always having
a strike here in this kind of moxies
will rule the working class.
we're all workers were all in the same
struggle,
etc.
Etc.
They were saying that we had to support.
We're going to support the workers in
South Africa.
We had to support the teachers.
Right,
but they think about this for a second.
Work is inside africa.
Farm workers are pool are so poor
because of trade policies that benefit
british farmers and european farmers or
farmers effectively and that
impoverished in marginalizes them in
their conditions or conditions that we
could never even contemplated.
Right now.
Teachers are paid out of taxation from
that very system which was floyd said
african farmers,
so women were.
When teachers are asking for paintings
and better pay,
what they're asking for is a better is
more fruits from the exploitation of
places like South Africa.
So in no way,
shape or form are these two people
together?
Actually they opposed to completely
opposed because teachers,
anybody on myself as well,
we make our money off their exploitation
and that's the psychosis of whiteness
because you can't understand the
actually your part,
we are,
all of us here are part of the problem,
not necessarily the solution,
but when you have a systemic
contradiction such as that one within
which your participation is voluntary,
other than like I've literally,
I'm out of the system now.
Like how do you avoid that aNd how can
alliances be formed on that basis,
that thinking then if you think of a
power like,
you know,
like I've what I thought was brilliant
that,
that oj documentary when to use it for
they use that oj simpson documentary,
a story about race in the United States
of America.
Stories about crime,
stories about commerce.
Capitalism a racial tension.
But I mean really in a way that I could
understand.
Tell me a lot of important stories.
And a lot of it was about a oj simpson's
racial identity at a time when the civil
rights movement,
when people were making huge sacrifices
and mohammed ali,
you know,
the sentence and gave up his belt and
all of that stuff.
But like there was an interesting moment
where it said,
well why does the oj simpson,
because he is an african american man,
half the obligation to be like,
well you've got white.
Like you wouldn't know why athlete or
white star would have that obligation
would be expected to carry that mantle.
So it began to sort of challenge what
whiteness and blackness mean as sort of
categorization system.
So like if like,
you knoW what this distinction I exceed
there is a historic colonial and indeed
contemporary continuation of these
themes and categories.
But,
but there,
there is this,
a crossover isn't there because let's
say barack obama as the,
when he was the president of United
States,
he was an african american man,
but he is in the,
if you use that argument about the south
african farmers,
the teachers who he is the puppet,
you know,
he's the president over folks on his
team.
How does that all work?
Yeah,
I mean,
and this is part of the thing with a
psychosis is I always say this isn't
just for white people in any way,
shape or form.
Let people live.
Many,
many,
many believable would also kind of
embrace this kind of psychosis.
All right?
I was one of the most critical people
still am one of the most critical people
of barack obama's presidency.
You have a black president for after
eight years,
literally every single indicator,
apartment,
employment.
And if a black people went down and even
if you look at employment,
black wages went down so much.
They actually,
employment was basically irrelevant.
And so you think then what we achieved,
what was achieved by these and actually
the celebration of obama,
particularly by african americans and
black people here in my mum cried when
obama was elected.
That's part of that psychosis,
right?
That we think things are changing when
actually if you look at the evidence
suggests that none of these things are
actually changing and in many ways to
get in,
they get worse.
So then what's the value of that as a
category?
If it is ultimately,
as you said,
literally meaningless.
In what sense is he an african american
president?
Other than like he's able to say how he
felt in shops and that kind of stuff.
And like,
you know,
like things that you fill in bloody
hell.
This is sort of amazing and a fist bump.
Avoidance of literally superficial,
which I suppose is sometimes what I
think race ought be in utopia.
Like in the,
a superficial monica.
It's what was the value and meaning of
it.
Would you say that there really wasn't
any?
Uh,
no,
there was.
So they'll,
you'll find some academics.
He will be very critical of obama.
But say,
well look,
it's limited what you could do.
That's the problem.
We can just move on.
It's not that big a deal,
right?
I'll tell you,
I'd actually take the opposite approach
and stated that the symbolism of obama,
the point of obama's blackness,
one of the reasons why he got elected
was part of to aid this idea of the
psychosis was to aid this idea of the
american dream.
For me.
Barrack obama's blacknEss is violent in
itself.
Go on.
Because what does it do?
What is.
So what is it that my mom's grinder and
mom was a radical in the,
in the,
in the sixties,
and all these politics about revolution,
etc.
Etc.
And she's crying on,
um,
on,
on the day this very near liberal
politician,
you never offered one single thing to
blake.
Never said he was gonna do anything for
black people,
but we just kind of assumed because he's
black,
there's going to have something.
Right?
And then you see afterwards,
everybody's kind of praising the symbol.
You've got black family in the white
house and obama with young black men,
but actually get belief that symbol.
What's that?
Trying to do,
that's trying to tell you that things
have progressed,
that things have changed,
that progress is being made,
but again,
look at every single indicator tells you
that from black people,
particularly in America,
things are getting worse,
probably not better.
And so the symbol of obama and why his
blackness,
how he used his blackness and why he got
one of the reasons he got elected is
because it keeps us more diluted and
tied into a system which can never
providers freedom,
justice or equality.
People will hate being told that story I
fancy
and probably not the most popular to put
things,
but it's also the truth,
right?
That's right.
So that,
that,
that type of critique,
we say no,
let's not get distracted by what appears
attractive and what appears beautiful
and promising.
Look at how power is actually behaving.
So like to return to my prior point
about like how do I as a white person
from a working class background whose
attitude is always been anti like me
reaching for my little slice of the pie.
I like,
um,
like a,
like how do I,
um,
participate what like how do I,
like when you say that about the british
empire,
right?
I sort of think like,
god,
yeah,
it's all built on like biscuit tins or
union jack on it and land and open glory
and light over the butcher and people in
India and africa and doing whatever was
required and,
and nation was always a front for
corporations anyway.
And the whole thing's been a black,
right?
I'm on board.
So like how do we have alliances that
aren't caught up in sort of bureau
bureaucracies such as that teacher,
south african farmer alliance.
How do we go,
well,
let's let the radical white folk in
there.
There'll be of some use.
Or is it like,
can it not work?
I,
this is the bar,
the material we some testing now.
It isn't maybe the best [inaudible] I'm
a big malcolm mixed fan.
I love medical mix and
may I know if that's all right with you
boys.
More the merrIer.
Deb backup as a story in geography where
malcolm white lady comes to ask them a
similar question,
what can white people do?
and he basically turns around and says
nothing and in walks up and he feels bad
about it.
You have malcolm x anyway,
probably a bit nervous.
He's an intense guy and she was crying
and she was really upset and he felt bad
about.
He's like,
okay,
I shouldn't said this actually.
Yep.
People have the responsibility to go
into white communities and making these,
these arguments.
Um,
I've already advanced much more than
that.
One of the things that malcolm used to
do was just to go round and tell white
people.
Literally they were devil.
I mean,
he'd say you do evil,
like what?
Look what you've done.
Look at this critique.
Um,
and I guess as,
as a black scholar,
an activist,
that's the most I can do.
I don't know if I can have the answer to
what you can do other than to prove the
critique.
Runk I would love to be wrong.
But actually if I'm looking
historically,
presently,
currently at the left as well as the
right,
I don't see how you break out of that
cycle.
That's why I call it a psychosis because
it's completely irrational.
There is nothing you can do to
penetrate.
And actually to my,
of my,
my,
my work is more about what we do as
black people.
We had a with,
of course that must be,
isn't it like how I would have a person
or allegiance around like addiction or
wherever because that's where,
that's just what I've been drawn to from
my particular wound,
like a.
And that's where I feel I know score on
that so I can be relevant and I can be
useful in that area.
I can't go around camp campaigning on
behalf of the group that aren't,
don't share the experience of,
um,
but what I feel like pure conjecture,
of course,
given the nature of what I've just said
might be the solution or my question is,
is it not that we weather these
categorize these categorizations are,
um,
but the way wherever we find ourself
within that sort of peculiar college,
all the light that we be the nine,
the cat,
like a suit,
a transcending the categories,
not the nine.
What the narrative is like.
I'm like,
I'm wars and his has happened and I'm
aware of it now in the industries I work
in.
I work when I'm at meetings around
television,
I think,
wow,
we're all white still.
I'm sort of aware of that into an but
like what,
what's,
and that sort of super relevant and,
but what I'm interested in is that as
long as our identity continues to
rewrite those categories,
even if it's through overflow in them,
we continue in somehow to augment them
by like,
you know,
like that by saying,
well,
no,
this is our story and this is what it
is.
I completely accept the importance of
it,
but how do we ever go,
right?
We don't win anymore.
We don't want power to work in that way.
How do we Challenge it in dismantling if
we are a wednesday two welded to somehow
to our categories?
Yeah,
and I think this is was,
um,
I think it really does.
It's really about taking onboard this
critique in a very serious way.
And I don't think the left the left is a
general thing,
but people on the left markets,
other academics have done this in the
sense.
So for example,
if you look at the mobilizations like
occupy,
occupy wall street,
we're the 99 percent.
I'm sorry,
that's an,
that's an offensive way to look at
global global inequality.
If you are in,
if you,
if you own the average wage in britain,
hearing someone like the top four
percent of earners in the entire world,
just recognizing that the conditions
that we are not just white people,
black people who live with have hear a
pause in a completely different
situation to the conditions of people in
the third world.
So for example,
there was recently a child bereavement,
enough inner family circle of friends
because a car accident and two years
later everybody's still shocked by it
and shook by it because it's so foreign,
but actually in many parts of the world,
children just die all the time when a
child dies every 10 seconds because they
haven't got access to food.
So what that means is we're protected
from that,
the horrors of the system.
So for us to pretend that we're all in
this one big happy family of workers
that that needs to go,
you say one thing to take that ethic of
the equation,
completely understand that all of us
here at a meeting included are complicit
in the system and benefit from this
system.
I don't think you see that in much of
the of the left.
Unfortunately that will be a starting
point and maybe you can build a proper
politics after that.
I sort of awakening.
Yeah.
Is that like what you said there like
that?
There's that famous orwell quote,
you know,
the british working class is in India
when I was on bill maher,
you have a day and like it's sort of a,
you know,
they very much romanticize a bomber and
like,
they're very much like the opening.
I like bill miner,
but the opening jokes were very much
about,
um,
you know,
sort of,
oh yeah,
well,
you know,
you're not a president.
Like about.
It was very romantic and nostalgic and
of that.
And then the subsequent conversation was
again,
sort of about intricacies of the,
you know,
the democratic party in the way they
elect candidates now for this is the way
you have trump is because this is,
this doesn't appeal to people on a
visceral level.
It,
you're,
you're not addressing the inability of
conventional politics to tell a
truthful,
open,
clear story.
Um,
so how does politics have to alter is
safe.
How do you end up in it like that?
Because I think both brexit and trump,
I see them more as failures of the left
or failures of progressive truly
progressive thinkers as opposed to
triumphs for the right.
So what,
what is the obligation of progressive,
even if you don't use the terms like
lifting rocks,
I can see how they're becoming
problematic and somewhat redundant and
they are part of the promo record,
but like this,
well,
it's in many ways the trump embracing a
response to the logic of the lift as
well in some ways if you have this
national politics that says,
well how do we get the next weekend for
the working class in the uk or the
working class in America,
which unfortunately a lot of the lift
has done.
Then being anti immigrant and being a
bit racist,
it makes sense.
Here's a logical thing that's a logical
thing to do.
That's the history of the lift,
particularly of britain as well.
So it really,
I mean,
it really thinking about the trade judy,
and think about like people always say,
let's go back to social democracy.
My family came to this country on the
social democracy.
They were colored bars,
couldn't get taught in school.
So you weren't,
um,
weren't allowed to join.
The trade union weren't allowed to vote.
I'm into this association,
couldn't live in this area,
et cetera,
et cetera.
Actually under social democracy,
the racism that we're experiencing now
and saying,
oh,
this is terrible.
It was like $5 worth right and left wing
social democracy working class.
And the racism was far more severe on an
open level than it is today.
So in some ways these aren't trump and
brexit on,
on,
on alien to the lift.
The tool is that if you even corbion got
criticized because he never really came
out about brexit and because there is a
strong left wing argument that guy can,
you know,
you want to protect wages,
etc.
Etc.
Because a lot of the left is framed
around the nation state,
right?
How do you protect britiSh workers,
how do you protect american workers,
et cetera.
And so what we need to do for the lift
is to have a much more radical approach
to politics.
And it's not like thIs never happened.
So if you look at people like eric told
him,
right?
And neo marxist,
he wrote,
he wrote a lot of work to the black
panthers,
american near marxist in the seventies.
I'm emmanuel wallace.
Dean talks about world systems theory,
so there is,
there is a theory that says,
look,
we need to basically divest of our
privileges in the west and really
understanding our place in the global
system that works there.
Unfortunately it hasn't.
It hasn't necessarily worked to
influence how politics work.
What do you mean divest of privilege?
I didn't like the sound of that
is about.
It's about acknowledging except as a
black man,
for example.
I have to understand that I don't suffer
most of the of racism,
right?
I,
I'm not unemployed.
I don't ask him by the police.
I have higher education.
I have,
I am one to most people in the country,
right?
So I have to understand that,
that I'm in a privileged position and I
have to understand also that because I'm
in the way that privilege come from,
it comes from the exploitation of people
that look like me,
which means I then have to build a
completely different politics that says,
how do,
how do we relate to the least of us in a
sense?
How do we draw these global idea?
But,
um,
child deaths and politics around the
world,
etc.
Etc.
Um,
And understanding that I to do this,
I'm going to have to give up my
privilege and this is what people don't
want to do.
Right?
This is why the probably the limit.
This is probably why I'll never work
because for us in the west to really
have a radical politics,
it will mean we have to give up
privileges and to what extent are people
willing to do that?
I suppose the power structures that
perpetuate all dependent on our
unwillingness to give up comfort.
If,
if people had a sort of.
I'm more spiritual,
I would want to say attitude towards
asceticism.
If people were kind of hardened to the
idea of no,
I know what's right and you're not going
to be guiding me with your iphones.
You're going to feel like.
But it's very,
very hard to get there a couple of times
a week I think.
Would I be more happy if I was to fill
my house with people who were refugees
started that I didn't like?
What would my sum tote of happiness go
up?
I'd send to be spending less time
reflecting on why shouldn't really be
having this privilege should I know,
but much more time we bloody hell.
We brought the toilet or whatever it
would be that day,
you know,
like so like,
but it requires it that I guaranteed it
this wicked speech about where he said
like,
you know,
so there's no point in us overflowing
the british then replacing them with a
comparable system.
You might have heard this given that you
have degree courses in racial politics
like so,
but there's a bit where he goes like,
you know,
the fact is it comes down to the idea of
our attitudes towards comfort.
As long as We are addicted to comfort,
then it's really hard on some level,
on a personal level,
you have to go like,
this is where.
This isn't theory,
This isn't something you read about
books,
scope.
Am I prepared to give up my only phone?
Would I be happier if I had less stuff
on?
On some level I sort of feel I would be.
And what prevent.
There's a kind of fear though,
indeed that prevents me from going,
right.
I'm just going to walk out into,
because I suppose my personal privilege
and wealth is what I feel protects me
from this system,
from this world.
Yeah.
And I,
I can see why people don't quite,
you know,
people know who wants to give up stuff,
right?
And particularly if you work in glass to
give you a blank,
um,
use this discrimination,
right?
So we're seeing that is clearly unequal.
It's clearly not fair and we fill it
badly treated as well.
So that's also part of the problem that
says,
what am I going to give up?
This have worked quite hard to get it as
well,
but unfortunately that's the reality.
Huey newton,
the black panther is a,
wrote a book,
a revolutionary suicide.
They said this is what revolution is
about.
Understanding that you have to be able
to give up for those people who are,
who are less than Mrs.
White.
I have very little faith in this
happening in europe.
And in effect,
the,
the concept we always talk about as a
radical concept is blackness because
he's,
my blackness is the way that I look at
this is the,
it's the hair is the,
that's a connection to people who are at
the literal bottle.
So when we talk about the child that
dies every 10 seconds,
the vast majority of those already in
africa.
Right?
So that gives me a connection that you
don't,
that you don't necessarily have right
now.
And that should give me a connection I
should have.
And that should tie me into politics and
remind me this is a global struggle,
not a national struggle,
which is why I have a bit more faith in.
That's kind of was kind of black
movements then I would have in,
in the us and european movement.
I guess
if however,
the only people that care about that
exploitation and you know,
even in the most severe form such as
child deaf,
are people that have a visible and
cultural identification with it.
And even then it remainS theoretical
impact.
I don't know what.
To what degree are you involved in
activism?
Like they're like,
how is anything going to change?
In fact,
it seems to me that until you get to
that point that huey newton point about
self sacrifice,
which is really martyrdom,
is an idea that again,
is resourced from theology.
You know,
how,
how without a spiritual component is
radical radical change going to occur
because how the human beings access
ideas such as one less true for
fraternity transcendence,
relinquishing individual identity
through social and cultural like or,
or material forms.
Like how'd you go?
You know,
because it doesn't have the necessary
potency is not emotive enough.
It doesn't seem.
Yeah,
I mean there's,
there's two parts.
I mean,
one I think in terms of you look at the
black struggle and that kind of global
politics.
There are people at friends fan on a.
We'll talk about the idea that user who
was a martinican I'm postcolonial
theorist and he will talk about that,
that you need to sleeping beauty of the
european working class to wake up
basically and you need those allies to
have this,
this,
this revolution.
Even the panthers would,
would have said this because they were
marxists.
Um,
because of like you said that you need
to have this almost spiritual.
It's something beyond just rationality,
something more than.
Yes,
this is why I say it's probably never
gonna happen,
right?
One,
we have a system which has always
protected the western working class who
always from the worst exploitation,
a provided comfort and wealth and
provided it as an outlet.
So look at the left.
Now they're saying,
look,
can we just get a bigger share of the
pie?
Not can we change global poverty?
Can we get a big share of that?
But yeah.
And so I'd be unlikely to see that
happen,
but can you see that kind of more
emotional if you like,
theological,
spiritual in this concept of blackness.
This is why log.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a potential possibility.
And rather than wait and try and get the
allyship of people who are dumping
river,
going to have massive allergy,
let's just go with what we have and
organize what we have and produce a
movement that can actually this,
that by itself would be enough to
destabilizing and kick the bucket a
little bit.
I see.
That's good.
But it's,
for me,
it's more entrenched in precisely
because of it's inability to transcend
systems of categorization.
There have been previously established
by the power dynamic that you seek to
overflow.
Well,
no,
because that's
the thing about,
about blackness.
I mean in some ways that you can say,
and this is the critique,
we get a lot lower.
This is racial categories that are from
europe,
et cetera,
et cetera.
But actually blackness is concept.
Talking about.
It's really the opposite to race a race
is about biology is about hierarchy.
It's about europeans looking at us and
saying,
you are not really human.
Blackness is,
oh,
this is looking at each other and going,
okay.
We've probably gotten the same african
background.
We've got that dissent,
uh,
we're seeing these europeans are doing
these terrible things.
They're trying to categorize it in this
way and we're going to reject that.
So blackness isn't a bad hierarchies in
the bad.
Biology isn't about genetics.
It's about saying there's a shared
shared meaning of color that's a shared
meaning of politics.
And we come together and organize in
order to benefit the community.
But it doesn't have those elements of
race,
so it's a different concept for me.
Now shifting the idea of reparations
because it's sort of,
I suppose it's a practical idea.
Can you talk to him about that?
That for western wealth is founded on
colonialism,
that there could be a redemptive
mentions or is that idea?
Um,
yeah.
So if basically if you look through
historically,
it's very clear and very obvious that
the wealth of the west is built on
slavery,
colonialism and genocide,
like very clear.
And if you just take slavery,
for example,
I mean slavery is about 300 year system,
uh,
places like britain.
America is literally built off the back
of it.
Parts of london.
Liverpool wouldn't really exist.
Glasgow in scotland,
scotland to get off the slavery.
But my son name's andrews,
so that should tell you everything you
need to know.
slavery and scotland,
birmingham,
even because it was not a poor we get,
we tend to get away as well from some of
these slavery stink if you like,
but the industry evolution,
james,
what matthew boat and they were all
heavily involved in slavery,
took lots and lots of money from
somewhere.
So if you think about the industrial
revolution,
which is typically seen to be the marker
of the west right,
and how progressive it is and scientist
cetera,
et cetera,
or the first real commodity that was
made in just revolution was cotton and
cotton grown in britain.
Right?
I mean they don't grow on it.
They got caught and was in America.
It was in the caribbean and so is that
that commodity and that wealth from,
from the cotton industry,
which was from the slave trade,
which really gets reinvested back into
the industrial revolution and therefore
you're able to have the rest of the
program,
etc.
Etc.
So the money that you needed to have
something like the industry revolution
is 100 percent tied up into,
into slavery.
So tHat's what we mean.
Birmingham,
for example,
made some,
some large proportion of all the guns
and all the shackles that were used in
the entire slaved rate.
We only made the guns in shackles.
They were barely involved.
Exactly.
British ships,
british,
even things like,
um,
finance capitalism,
insurance starts with the slave trade.
Lloyd's of london,
you celebrate it.
I think it was 400 years anniversary of
the day.
The ceo comes on tv and says we're happy
to have our roots in ensuring the
merchant trade.
And what she meant was literally the
slave trade.
That's what you talk about,
slave trading in lloyd's of london,
the merchant rate psychosis,
but just a few ships tried to sporting
goods.
So you can see the roots of that.
Financial institutions are cities ever.
You probably couldn't have much of the
world that we have today with it,
without slavery.
Capitalism,
I suppose,
you know,
like one component in it,
like,
you know,
sort of creating excess value at excess
worth.
SO anythiNg you can do to reduce
overheads,
like,
like we found ways of reducing the next
stuff from other countries.
Get other people to work for no money at
all.
And that's really,
that's the all the line and the unicorn
and the land and the hope of glory.
It's,
that's what it,
yeah,
I mean that's 100 percent and what it
does consume.
And so if you think about reparations in
America,
most of this work has been done in
America and they tried to calculate,
um,
I'm pretty strong legal precedence,
so 300 years of unpaid,
unpaid labor.
You just work out what the labor would
have been,
what the cost would have been,
what people should have got paid for the
work that they did.
Um,
and then there's also a precedence
around trauma and abuse.
So for exAmple,
for the holocaust he talked about
earlier,
germany's paid airbags like $90 million
or something like that because the
numbers are maybe more than germany's
actually paid out reparations for the
harm.
That was cool.
So let me say these two categories and
say that you've got to pay for unpaid
labor.
You've got to pay for trauma.
Uh,
in the states,
they reckon it's anywhere between four
point nine and 15 point 6 billion
trillion trillion dollars that's owed to
african americans.
It would essentially unravel that's
nation,
that system as we know it.
That's why it can't be countenanced
thought discussed because you can't have
the United States of America.
Now that we're,
again,
we're framing it economically.
And I read this wicked thing off of
this.
A native american,
he called himself or maybe even of
Indiana,
I can't remember,
like a,
like activist and he said all these sort
of systems,
you don't come up with marxism
capitalism,
they're all sort of your ideas when in
and none of them were best.
We have a completely different framework
for understanding reality.
But,
and you can see that with something like
reparation that what begins to unravel a
national identity,
it will curious.
I fought in that James Baldwin
documentary where he goes,
that the whole category of negro is
required in order for,
uh,
the doormen and pat the dog,
the dominant power,
I don't know,
sort of force to have,
uh,
enough,
identity to cast a shadow onto that.
That category is created in order for
whiteness to prevail,
not only economically,
but also kind of psychologically because
in a way economics is there sort of an
external system that comes from
somewhere and it,
and as,
for all forms of categorization master
that they,
these,
that I suppose one of the things that
we're arguing these,
there is no essence to categorization
these external forms that
retrospectively except for that moment
where you talked about blackness is
having some veracity in terms of visual
identification.
But I was,
I was sayiNg then the um,
the,
how,
like with that reparation argument you
can't.
So in a sense like what would happen if
they give you,
pursue that?
Where does that go?
Yeah.
Well guess this is,
this is the,
the cool de sac of reparations is on
word to put it.
I dunno.
So logically there's no real argument
against reparations.
Look at.
So you look at,
so people talk about,
oh it was a long time ago,
things have passed,
etc.
But actually the effects is still very,
very,
very clear.
not just what are the descendants of
enslaved but also in africa.
I mean,
just the populating africa today,
extend alone has had a huge negative
impact on the economy so you can see the
effects of slavery as though their
reparations were paid to the slave
owners.
Imagine that and actually gave her
praises tO this label because it was
that there was that much money involved.
They will have to give me some money.
Right?
They serve.
Sorry.
Losing single slaves must be terrible
hardship.
Exactly.
There was a.
You'd a ucl unIversity college london,
just a legacy of british slavery project
and they've traced where the equivalent
of 2 billion pounds that went to the
british owners of slaves at the
emancipation wind and you can see it's
in the church is in the middle classes
in david cameron's family.
It's literally forever for the economy,
so it's very clear there's a problem and
it needs to be restitution paid for that
problem,
but you're right though,
when you start to add up these numbers,
I mean if it's 15 trillIon in in the
states,
what would that be for the uk?
You talking about?
You can't.
It's impossible.
It's literally impossible for the west
to pay these kind of sum of money.
It would destroy.
It would destroy us.
There is no west in order to do it.
It means that the west has to dismantle
itself.
The power,
In fact,
don't all arguments about power reach
this nexus that well,
in order for the power to respond
correctly,
it would have to dismantle itself
whether you're,
say you're talking about a transnational
corporation,
if you're too matt lloyd's,
lloyd's in order to behave rationally
and acknowledge its origins would have
to not be lloyds anymore or gmo for that
time.
they were putting out cars they knew
were going to catch fire,
but it works out cheaper to let it
happen.
The only sort of possible responses for
there not to me.
So the systemic changes required are so
absolute that they in a sense defy the
dynamic because it's like if,
uh,
if you say right America,
britain,
colonial,
former colonial or colonial nations have
to repeat it.
But,
and what I feel like is that
transference of wealth to africa,
if,
unless there is systemic change or you
have now is now the dominant forces
within africa behave in that way and in
a way isn't it a bit of a red air in,
in that it's sort of,
I think is it still happening,
are sort of very simplistic,
unproductive but bloody hell.
What did you expect when you came on in?
Like,
like sort of my argument is a bit like,
but people sort of.
It goes a bit like this,
right?
You can't have slavery no more people
have like it's bothering too many.
People are like,
I've got influence,
but what we can have is will pay people
the absolute bare minimum.
There'll be a subjugated under cloud.
So things just move on.
If power finds a way of manifesting
itself continually and making the
minimum compromises,
which is why I think this is where the
power of the reparations argument you
follow it through to its logical
conclusion,
tells you that the problem is
irresolvable within our political and
economic system,
and this is where you need to have a
radical change and actually what we
should be organized will revolutionize
the change you need to have.
Their institution needs to be made,
cannot be made in this.
Again,
to quote medical mix.
Uh,
this system is,
um,
it's impossible to have freedom,
justice and equality for black people in
the same way that it's impossible for a
chicken to late a duck egg.
It's just not meant to happen.
Right?
And once we realized it will start
thinking of much bigger solutions to our
problems,
that's the power of,
for me,
that's a pair of their operations
argument to tell you how see how's
embedded in the system is actually quite
brilliant.
Yeah,
it is.
Because it leads you to the point and
going,
yeah,
but hang on a minute.
If you did that,
there would be no America.
And then that tells you,
oh,
America is therefore built on it.
Exactly.
And that's the problem.
So let's think about different solutions
and when you think about power manifests
and inch and giving concessions,
this is kind of what we see with the
reparations debate.
So carrie con,
which is a caribbean collection of
caribbean countries,
are currently arguing for reparations
and there they've kind of stopped asking
for money.
Now it's about can we get some
development aid?
Can we get an apology?
Can we get some education,
will do tHe apology for it,
for it.
It's a different set of demands,
a set of demands that the west could do,
right?
It's not impossible.
They could do this and then it could
absolve them of theIr guilt to say,
well look,
we,
yeah,
we apologize.
We gave you this development aid.
We wiped off third ward did,
but it actually didn't change the
problem.
Problem is doing it.
The issues are still there.
The structures are still there.
So you can actually do reparations in a
way that makes things worse,
not better.
Unfortunately.
Yes,
I say,
but it's like it's one of those spreads
that if you pull out it,
things fall apart.
It makes me your right.
So what kind of,
what are you going to spend the rest of
your,
I mean you might not know,
but what,
what were your most immediate objectives
in terms of bringing about change?
Where do you like now that you know all
this stuff now,
the teacher,
the staff in your position,
you're in what you're gonna do.
Um,
so I think in terms of the book I'm
coming out next year,
black black radicalism is a manifesto of
theory theoretically,
but also practically they say,
well actually what is black radicalism
mean?
What does this politics do?
What does it lead us to?
And where it leads us to is to an
organization that transcends a nation
state that connects us to the poorest
and the most abject,
that condition.
And so it's actually less work on
building revolution.
and so it's kind of built on 'em.
So when malcolm x,
like you,
I probably have mentioned malcolm like
10 more times before we,
before we finished where malcolm dies,
he's working on the organization of afro
american unity.
He says this organization is,
is the revolutionary organization
because you have a,
you have a place here,
you have a place in New York place in
caribbean,
a place in Jamaica replacing and garner
a place in all over the world and you
connect this organization together and
now you've got that kind of unity and
solidarity across borders.
They can actually have a proper
revolutionary change.
so this is the word I'm trying to do
currently.
Hey,
what do you think is the significance of
malcolm x's islam?
To me it was a muslim.
It was a lack of proper cloth.
He was a devout muslim like you because
you're coming at him from the angle of
being a black man in england.
2017,
like,
like isn't as much or could it be argued
that is it a muslim icon as well as a
african american or black icon?
And how did those categories in a sec,
particularly in a climate where
islamaphobia,
so president.
Yeah,
so I think malcolm question came out of
nowhere.
Being a muslim is a.
He's not incidental,
right?
And actually malcolm,
when malcolm becomes really radical,
some outcomes in the nation of islam for
about 13,
13 years when he comes out of prison and
it transforms him,
but the nation of islam is very much a
religious organization in that he says
that the solution to people's problems
is to become muslim and that's kind of
the.
You just become muslim and as a prophecy
where god's going to wipe away all the
white people and we'll be fine.
So we need to do is be muslim and he
sees that that's,
that's the kind of religion,
whether it's islam or christianity or
whatever it is that you don't want to
have basically because it limits you and
you don't really do anything.
You just pray.
And eventually malcolm leaves because he
sees the limits of any because it
becomes a sunni sunni,
sunni muslim.
He goes,
he goes,
he goes to.
He goes to maker.
He has a.
He has a different kind of islam and he
becomes in many ways more developed so
he finds the mosley must incorporate,
but very clearly in the ballot or the
bullet speech in [inaudible] 64.
He says,
start a speech,
says,
look,
I'm a muslim,
but you need to leave your religion at
home.
Keep your religion between you and your
gut because this is not.
This is not what we're talking about
when we do this organization work.
This is black people stuff and you can
be whatever religion you want to be,
but it has no impact on the politics.
So malcolm makes it very,
very clear separation.
Do you think that was a political move
knowing that there was actually a
trenchant christianity,
even black population in America that
time?
He didn't want to caUse a rift in that
way,
but I think
so important philosophically because I
think he's saying he's just saying that
religion is that religion is something
that makes you connect to the world and
makes you.
It gives you spirituality and it gives
you something personally.
Religion is not something that can solve
any of our problems on earth.
Yeah,
but that's,
to me mate,
is the big argument of secularism that
religion is a private matter.
uh,
the,
um,
whereas I think of like spirituality,
not religion because it's such a hot
potato as having the motivational power
to bring about the kind of revolution
revolution that's required because I
don't,
you know,
if you're sort of when you sort of get
start to tee up on that precipice that
you'll take into by thinking when you
pursue that reparation argument when you
think,
oh my god,
that would mean the dismantling of the
entire,
uh,
europe as we understand it and the
United States of America as we
understand it.
It also sort of revealed he didn't
narratives the way around.
The way that power transcends nation has
continued historically massed by flags
and our own willingness to participate
in their rituals.
Whether it's consumer rituals or daft
secular holidays.
And suddenly all of this is exposed.
And I think that if you're asking people
to take on board ideas as radical as you
know,
as simple as radical,
as seemingly trivial as put down your
phone and start caring about little kids
down a mine,
the only way they're going to do that is
we have some connection to something
transcendent.
And I don't know.
And I obviously say this is a white
person and I was really enjoying the
moment mate where I was talking to you
about malcolm x.
I was like,
there's bits where I was going to
contradict you.
I thought this is good.
This is good stuff.
Professor of black studies now.
Yet again on the subject of malcolm x,
my feeling is that people are going to
need to find a resource that's extremely
potent in order to countenance such
sacrifice.
And I know the civil rights movement in,
in its origins,
you know,
like sort of them early student type
prOtests where then girls got murdered
and.
All right,
I've read the brilliant thing.
I think it bothered that malcolm
blackboard.
So it's pretty good pop thing.
But you're saying that the kind of
allegiances were formed.
Then what sort of local communal and
tight and he was,
I think it was an essay on house or the
limitations of social media and how like
you need sort of proper connections,
but then people also were christian in
that like,
you know,
there were other sort of like they were
transcendent belief systems like whereas
you said very plainly and overtly there
boldly that religions not going to do
nothing.
Well,
like I don't feel like,
you know,
mark,
I'm very,
very evident to me the way that religion
is used to sort of categorize subjugate
divided to the shame and all those
things.
But I feel like how can we transcend
these systems of categorization unless
it is by saying they read some essence
to the self and some essence to the
whole world.
I mean,
I think,
like I said,
I don't think so.
Even even with malcolm,
he says,
look,
split the two you couldn't separate is
islam from his politics.
Right.
And I think that that does motivate
people to do things.
I think the key thing is to say that
there isn't one religious answer and I
think that's what math was basically
trying to say is if you're a christian
and these motivate you,
if you're a muslim is motivate you.
If you were jewish and it motivates you
or whatever religion you are,
we use that to motivate you,
but actually in terms of the program,
in terms of what we're going to do in
terms of where we go next in terms of
the alliances that we make,
religion just going to get into weight.
I every level.
Right,
and separate and saying that look,
the earthly problems that we have with
the problems that we have and in some
senses blackness.
The way malcolm talks about the.
We'll talk about it has that version of
spirituality to it.
Has that other connection to it
been the same way as you were saying
that malcolm x meant when he was saying
religion will get in the way.
What was ultimately a rice get in the
way?
If like if you take your argument of
blackness as the motivate in a sort of
bond for a sort of a revolutionary
movement,
where,
where does that,
what's the goal of that?
Where does that.
We've won the war.
Yeah,
so the idea is always like I guess if
you look at malcolm's politics will be
revolutionary panafricanism at the
african revolution and in and that's
kind of when you've got rid of europe
and China is agitating,
you've got different economy,
you've got politics,
right?
But that's never,
that's never been the end for that.
Politics always said,
well look,
african and black people in general
contact pot in the global revolution
because we ain't got nothing.
Like we don't have anything sweet.
Or where was the.
Nobody at kohl's on I'm blabbing have
enough.
But when you have a power base and If
you could do this revolution,
that revolution could.
That would firstly probably undermine
western capitalism to the point he would
no longer exist,
but he would give you the ability to,
to join in with other revolutions and
other groups and other and support those
groups.
So the black,
the black revolution is if you let the
starting point to the global revolution,
but you have to have that black
revolution first.
I guess the argument.
Yeah,
that's sort of my.
Why is that?
Why would you,
why would it have to stop?
Because that has to be at the level of
the most oppressed or most severe.
Why?
Well,
I know.
I guess in theory you could have say the
equistar in China because the other
parts of the world.
But if we're saying look from a,
from a black perspective,
you say look,
this is.
And also if you take that logic of the
most severe,
the worst depression,
there is a strong argument for africa
being that place.
And I suppose my motivating because of
the
economic ramifications as well,
like if africa as a continent says we
don't want trans,
like all of that,
we want a clean slate from that.
So in a bloody hell when you think about
that debt cancellation stuff,
it's not like a.
And as an active large,
yes we will cancel that debt.
What we give you by nikudos stuff and
it's not like an act of kindness is it
has in stopping,
so in adding insult to injury,
again,
I keep going back up again,
but he's a great and in the metaphors he
says,
if you,
if you stab me in the back and then pull
out a knife six inches,
then I can't.
I'm not going to thank you for that.
And this one day cancellation
effectively is like pulling out a knife
six inches.
The knife still there.
You haven't told him that you haven't
changed the debt cancellation debt in
the first place was just a neo-colonial
tool to keep people in a nice no.
So none of the things that the west will
ever offer you is really is really
solving the problem.
You've got to take the knife out and
heal the wound.
How do you get on with making these
arguments outside of academia?
How'd you get on with a young black
people that are not within academia?
How do you convey these kinds of ideas?
Do you remember too?
Is that.
Yeah,
I mean it's the same.
So like we started the organization of
black unity,
this is one of the things that's the
kind of the root of it.
So we took,
literally took malcolm when he died,
before he dies,
has a organization of afro american
unity as a constitution,
which nobody ever talks about it and it
says,
listen,
this is what you should do.
And we said,
okay,
let's do that.
Let's just see what,
see if it works.
And so we're working in birmingham to
get to talk to people,
would talk to young people,
older people.
Uh,
we're in an early stage,
but we know we're constantly having
these conversations as like campus on
campus as well.
And you'll be probably not surprised
people relate to them.
People understand them.
People get this.
This world doesn't,
couldn't even provide for them.
Yeah.
Because I suppose even if you don't
economic,
if you don't know it,
we've knowledge as it were,
like a in terms of information.
I mean if you don't know the
information,
somehow know it,
you know,
in your gas.
There's something I think in people that
resigns,
you know,
when people talk a lot about political
apathy,
I think it's like it's not apathy.
Is it rational?
Oh,
that's that
dude.
We've participate in that.
Yeah,
and people don't.
We haven't given people the opportunity
to be involved,
particularly in radical politics and
radical politics.
I mean,
radical has become a bad word in
general,
right?
We throw it around about islam and
terrorism and etc.
Etc.
But actually what we've done with this
is we've completely misunderstood what
radical is.
So radical islam and jihadism,
extremism and the complete opposite
things like completely not believable.
So extremism is when you take the,
the basic premise of a society or an
idea and you take it away forever,
then it makes any sense of ticket,
right?
That's ms dot.
That's what we're having with these
terrorists,
right?
That's the same as nazis.
That's the same as christie
fundamentalist,
etc.
And radIcalism is the opposite
radicalism.
You take the fundamentals and you reject
them.
He said,
well actually I don't want these.
I don't like this.
So you look at capitalism and you say,
look,
now I'm going to be a market store.
You look at going to be a radical and
you rejected.
So in a sense you can't actually have
radical islam because radIcal islam
would cease to be islam.
Just wouldn't be,
would be something else.
So we've completely conflate extremism
and radicalism and made radical a dirty
word.
We actually radical.
That's where we need to be.
That's where we need to be pushing
people toward.
That wasn't a coincidence then you think
that that word has been deliberately
tarnished because if you think,
um,
what's 50 only 50 years ago?
See,
late sixties,
it wasn't.
People really underestimate that.
The fact that we were on the precipice
of global revolution,
I mean really if you think of communism
in the east african continent is massive
politics there.
South America,
there was a,
there was a moment where I look like the
west may not with the maintenance of
life.
And since then they have this literally
destroyed with both violence,
physical violence,
and also symbolic violence,
uh,
destroyed radicalism.
So they told us that radicalism is Bad
relative to the wrong radicalism is
violent.
Radicalism is all these things and
pushed us away from those radical
movements.
But really radical movements are the
solution to these,
to these problems.
The only solution to these problems.
Can we criticize some contemporary
figures and you've got some,
lIke a proper,
a provocative quotes and stuff.
Eg,
what about that theresa may's worse than
Donald Trump?
That's
was that provocative.
Mostly it was illogical packet for us.
Well,
and again,
I say quote medical lady said elisha,
like literally,
I just quote medical books.
I do call other people as well,
but he always used to come up that came
from a paper.
I've just really literally in a book
about,
um,
malcolm distinguish between the southern
wolf who is kind of bare their teeth and
a very aggressive and very Openly
racist.
You got to know there the problem
because they're banging on your head and
they'll shoot you,
et cetera.
But he actually says that worse in the
southern wolf is the northern fox who's
the tricky,
who's counting,
who tell you,
tell you everything's fine in this
whisper.
Sweet nothings into your ear,
but really they're just as bad.
And if you think about racism at the
time,
uh,
in America and the civil rights movement
is all about the south and it was about,
you know,
the southern wolf was about segregation.
It was a bad,
let's,
let's get rid of this overt racism,
but any of the north,
we know you haven't got legal
segregation is,
it's actually more segregated in the
north than it is in the sale.
And look at looking today.
Nowadays,
look at the police killings.
They usually in the know of another set
of look at the ghetto that's often not
the same as well.
And so even though the north telling you
all these wOnderful tales by,
so it's just as bad and in some ways
it's worse than itself.
So this is the kind of thing I was
saying with the Theresa May.
Donald trump is very,
very clearly openly white supremacist
racist,
obviously quite proud of it seemingly.
Right,
like a white supremacist racism that was
revealed with that charlottesville
moment,
or is there other stuff that
historically,
in the nineties there was a big case in
central park where there was the,
um,
there was a rape in central park and it,
and it was,
it was pinned on a group of gang raid.
This,
these african americans gangs were
supposedly gang raped.
This white woman complete lie,
a complete fabrication.
Who was there trump champion this myth,
Donald Trump.
But Donald Trump was there,
one of the worst offenders in this,
uh,
central park five rape case.
Then you've got barack obama is not
american who was championing Donald
Trump.
Donald trump was hugely proud of that.
And now you've got the muslim band,
you've got charlottesville,
you've got all these,
look at it as very racist.
And he just raises historically,
directly personally listened.
I'll be surprised,
but Theresa May has tried to clothe
herself and being,
um,
you know,
so when she was home secretary,
she was,
um,
the police stop and search.
She ordered a review into stop and
search and just the other day she had
all the race antiracist campaigners in
her office around this.
Um,
let's look,
talk about racism.
Let's tell you the stats that I could
have told you the day before,
but anyway,
we're going to have a big parade about
how bad the countries.
He likes to pretend that she's,
she's good on race,
but she's terrible.
I mean she's as home secretary and if
you look at the policy around migration
visas for people from african countries
denying people enter into the country
letting.
I mean,
she literally had a policy that said
we're not going to send boats into the
mediterranean to save brown and black
people were just going to let them drain
to deter other people from coming.
I mean,
that's a dead negro policy.
It's what she's basically saying.
All right.
So if you look at government policy,
look at what she's done.
She's terrible and race,
but she presents herself as being
someone you can talk to,
someone you can relate to.
That's the northern route,
which is more dangerous,
right?
Yeah.
I feel that that's correct.
I like that,
um,
as a slogan that stop over racism,
overt racism,
overt racism out of football.
I've been mapping my subtle racism now,
but they're covert structural stuff.
There's crafty racism.
I'm like,
so the donald argument,
they something like,
gosh,
is it not an easy argument for a white
person or an english person to make?
And I'm both of those things.
You only one of them.
So like,
uh,
is this something to be said?
The,
the,
the grotesque amplification at the trump
represents the seven wolf argument that
there was something beneficial in that.
It's an honor ignorable hideous
carbuncle mr.
Oh my god.
We're now confronted with what our
society means.
Whereas as long as you had,
as you said,
there was a different kind of violence
immeshed in barack obama in the
concealment and the apparent book.
See,
we've got a black president,
but you know,
do,
do you think that there is something
depending on where it leads to almost,
if not positive,
cathartic about.
Yeah,
I say it might sound controversial,
but I'd rather have Donald Trump as a
president than barack obama.
Honestly,
I mean,
really in terms of racial issues,
it's just clear,
it's obvious is it tells you exactly
what you need to know about this
society,
whereas a bomb was fronting is making it
seem like it's something,
it's not.
And so if you look at the,
uh,
the protests,
you look at the movements,
look,
people get angry about things that's
there now in a way.
It wasn't necessarily the,
I mean,
it's not like he wasn't there completely
in black lives matter emerges under
obama,
partly becaUse I think people will,
like,
we've got a black president in,
shouldn't we expect a bit more?
yes.
But I think if you look now who look at
definitely the rhetoric around America
is racist.
This is problem.
Did it at a.
I think you've seen that comeback more
and that's what we need.
That's the starting point for the kind
of politics that we need.
Donald trump,
hero of african american.
Uh,
I will,
I won't go that far but,
but yeah,
bad precedent for hours I always say at.
I'll put it on record with Donald Trump
is the president of black America than
barack obama.
Wow.
That's cool because like the thing that
seemed sort of where that appeals to me
is that the,
I think,
and this is obviously a personal thing
as opposed to a cultural thing for me,
is I don't like bullshit.
I don't like the feeling that we're not
actually dealing with the problem.
It's always made me feel uncomfortable
and it's made me want to tip over
tables.
It's made me want to be explosive and to
sort of release a kind of romantic
volatility into the atmosphere because I
feel like no,
this isn't real and it's something that
was a person or it comes from a personal
experience,
but perhaps there isn't no distinction
between personal,
political experiences on some level.
I felt as a kid there's something ain't
right and at score for this isn't right.
Like that filled that truth is not being
conveyed on a very sort of practical
level.
What will that.
While I was at school feeling like I
don't feel like this is a beneficial
experience that I'm having.
I'd like an interest in my little belly,
so like I would at least like,
yeah,
like I sort of like,
oh,
right,
these geezers and also in it,
like as the president now,
right?
Oh,
I get it now.
See now pro power isn't pretending to be
your friend anymore and I don't see how
any,
the only sense of attachment or
connection or ajit,
ajit,
uh,
um,
affection.
Anyone could have a.
Donald trump will be like,
that guy looks like how I feel kind of,
I feel angry and I don't like life and
he looks like that feeling as a
president.
So you know,
like I can't imagine how anyone could
have any real,
legitimate sense of allegiance that you
feel like,
well,
what do you feel like with that
charlottesville?
Do you feel like,
ah,
I suppose you don't feel like it's your
problem.
But sometimes when I feel like,
um,
when like white people are marching
around with tiki torches in
charlottesville or wherever it's about
statue or something that seems to sort
of really sort of know necessarily in
literally abstract in fact that is
dealing with a symbol a lot.
Like your life will not get better if
you pursue your argument to it's natural
conclusion of repatriation or wherever
easily into your personal life will not
improve.
How do you.
Do you not consider that to be part of
the argument that is required by like
say black community?
Do you see it much more focusing on
creating solidarity?
Yes.
Well no.
I mean this is the,
the counter argument to the,
to the whiteness stuff,
unless you look at them,
probably a chunk of the people in
charlottesville,
a number of the people who voted for
Donald Trump,
white people,
they're not really getting anything out
of voting for Donald Trump to get rid of
your healthcare.
Whoever made these crazy decisions all
the time to actually vulgar with things
which make their situation worse,
much worse.
Right.
And I guess that's the kind of
counterargument to this whiteness thing.
If you could tell people,
listen,
if they could understand these and maybe
they would actually,
their interests will be better served
with the big.
A lot of people with everybody else,
right?
With a different kind of politics are
there.
The thing that I've felt for a little
while is that the way that power
operates is there must be a strata of
people in institutions for whom the way
that systems operate are not problematic
for,
for whom the systems are functioning
correctly.
There's a struggle going,
no,
there is no problem because this is
perfect.
This is doing what it's meant to do.
Then.
Right.
And I sort of think,
oh,
okay,
I'm not in that.
Then there's another one that's a
privileged elite that whether it's like
for someone like me this from an
entertainment background that's like,
oh,
I'm pretty cool.
I'm greg over.
I want to do,
I want as long as I don't rock the boat
as I found out when I did it,
but I agree.
And like,
um,
and then beyond that,
it's just various degrees of fucked
going down and down and down to you've
got nothing,
you know?
And if it isn't part of the problem that
people that they,
it's very difficult that once your,
you know,
both of us in our way and now included
in culture in a way like,
well that's pretty good.
We've got status power so that most
people go,
oh,
I don't see him as batman and find it
hard to,
you know.
What was that thing you said about
privilege,
yet?
Yes.
I think this is.
This is part of the pump.
I think also it's really important to
think about when you say it as those
layers of people who it's not a problem
for.
I would extend that to more people than
probably most people would extend that
to.
I think that's important,
right?
Even the poorest person in this country
doesn't deal with child death really on
a daily basis.
It doesn't,
doesn't have those exclusions and so
they may have problems and they may be
huge problems of inequality,
but with the politics that we're
mobilizing,
are we just trying to make it a bit
better for people here or are we trying
to make it better for everybody and I
think there is a consensus.
You could come to say,
well look,
you have a bit of rich little bit pulled
out,
will equal arabic and everybody will be
perfectly happy,
but it wouldn't solve the problem for
child death in public yet.
so.
Great.
I agree.
And I must be taught to care hindi
though.
They,
that,
that argument can be made from the right
to demotivate people.
I think that even the poorest people in
this country,
you're doing all right.
At least you're not dealing with some
bad kid in a mine.
And they're like,
I need more say steve,
what was it?
What,
what do you think being an educator,
what do you think are the obligations
from,
uh,
from their perspective of education?
What should we be being taught the
reality of colonialism and imperialism
with that?
What impact would that have?
Um,
I mean,
I think that's important.
So what,
what is the reality like?
What is,
I mean you think about empire and think
about we,
the people don't know,
you can't judge people for what they
don't know.
And unfortunately we don't know.
That system is terrible at telling us
things which are really important.
So I think teaching about empire,
just teach just that if you just say,
well,
let's teach an honest account of where
did britain gates will from where it is
brain sustain his wealth to date and
understand how the global system works
and how the global system privileges us.
I think if you could just eat that,
that will be a starting point,
but then it will be.
But I think it's a bit more than that.
So for example,
with the black studies degree,
uh,
that we started,
we have these arguments,
but then we put them into practice.
So they said,
well,
what are you going to do about it?
How are you going to mobilize?
What does that mean to how you act in
the community?
How do you as an actor,
as an academic,
I can just be an academic.
I have to be an activist.
They have to be a member of the
community,
have to be building these organizations
and doing this work and really teaching
people that they have a responsibility
to make this better.
The he kind of is a comment on us with
the privilege to make things better.
I think that's important as well.
Both of those things are important.
The first part it seems like I can
imagine that feeling like a kind of
heresy,
which makes me recognize again how
arbitrary the distinction between what
you call one course,
the religious and what one calls the
political,
how that line is arbitrary because if
you are in a school guy,
right?
This is what british empire is with that
nice in depth analysis in africa.
We've done that in Ireland and the
outcome you can have your coco pops
enjoy lunch and I was like,
no,
don't say that.
It's going to ruin everyone's morale.
It's sports day tomorrow,
right?
That's the first thing I'm going to say,
and with that black studies course,
how's it going and how many people were
on it and is it all black people?
Yeah,
so he's going,
well first year we've got about 20
students,
which is what we expected to get without
a target to get a.
It is actually usable by people for the
first time.
I'm sure in America,
african american studies is lies.
Lots of white people,
asian people.
It takes a while to.
To the stuff?
Yeah.
What about that woman that felt like she
was black in that?
do you remember that story?
Which one is an idea?
So I feel like I'm black actually.
So like what does that,
what did we go with that?
Is that interesting?
Because I was a duke university didn't
mind it may or something and I was
giving a talk about blackness,
citrus,
citrus and african american studies
department and somebody turned around
and said,
well actually the way you're talking
about blackness being this political
concept stage,
was it true?
Doesn't that mean rachel dolezal is
black?
And I was shocked.
I mean I couldn't believe it because
african american studies.
I thought it had been a bit more nuance
that's not really covered the basics,
but I think if somebody like that,
I mean if you're taking.
If,
if,
if I'm,
if my argument is that right,
the
color of my skin is important because of
the history of it in work it tells about
me and what it tells me about the
connections into.
Then you quite just faked it like you
guys make that up life.
That's the thing that unites you
politically then to try to pretend to
complete not only destroyed any concept
of unity sense,
so it's utterly offensive,
but I wouldn't ever get really mad about
this because you probably just got
mental health problems.
I mean real,
real level.
I wanting to be black later,
really want to be black.
What is that?
That takes a particular distorted view
of the world.
I liked the music in the edge,
not so keen on the slavery.
Yeah,
I see.
That's interesting because identity
politics can become very divisive in as
well as creating great cohesion and
momentum and this is a moment I feel
around these kinds of ideas and I
suppose as a white male,
I'm uniquely qualified to pontificate on
all facets of that guy and that was an
amazing interview.
I really,
really enjoyed it.
I feel properly like educated on a broad
area of topics.
Plus we got stuck in with some real
populism.
I think notably the moment of Donald
Trump is a bad precedent for black
american and barack obama.
That some radicalism,
right?
Hopefully people will put.
People's.
Mothers will put a picture of donald.
Donald trump won the war after I said
that.
That's what your mom cried when Donald
Trump becomes president.
He's going to cry with.
Listen to this.
Nice one.
Thanks mate.
Cheers.
This show is sponsored by my book
recovery,
which is a number one best seller in the
United Kingdom and New York times best
seller.
Go amazon gay at wherever you are in the
world,
particularly Ireland.
Actually,
we're not selling enough of them to
irish people.
Come on.
Irish people you know,
I love you.
I'm coming to your country soon.
Also,
come see me on my rebirth tour like a
london 51st and first photo 1st of
October,
1st of November.
Remember,
I'll be reading a book there.
That special recovery event.
Imagine come in,
they're having a book.
shout within your face,
getting something signed,
then having a drink for an hour.
Then I come back out and starts doing
all my jokes.
I was going to be great.
November the second,
and I'll be in a not an 8th of November.
Coventry 13th.
I'll be in leicester.
Ah,
the glory of the lord.
Finally,
if you like the show,
subscribe to it,
review it,
give it a five star review,
use unusual language and words,
really express yourself in that review.
I love you and we will continue to learn
together and together together,
together and together and together and
together.
Yeah.